every moment every beat is mapped out
talking about a month-long process just
for that 15 seconds stranger things is
easily one of the most terrifying shows
on netflix we've seen demogorgons mind
players and now we've got becknell
lurking around waiting for our cape bush
cd to skip have you ever wondered what
the show would look like without the
visual effects bringing these creatures
to life let's get into it okay
special effects
number one
the duffer brothers only knew a few
things for certain about the demogorgon
they wanted him to come from another
dimension and have a human body type the
body type was really important to them
because they wanted to be able to put an
actual person inside the costume for
season one shooting purposes
very quickly we realized okay so
practical isn't always
in season four however they brought in
animation the first animation pass
that's when you're seeing what looks
almost like just a gray clay rendering
the first pass is really important
because that's when they can hammer out
the details like how long they want him
to roar for example after that they get
to the rendering stage that's where the
fun really starts everything they've
shot all the animation and real life
stunts get to coexist together it's
really exciting when those shots finally
come together and all the elements
number two
the demogorgon is one thing but the
actual fight scenes require a different
approach a good portion of time the
demogorgon is just a guy in a green suit
sometimes he would have a
tennis ball at the top of his head to
show us how tall the demogorgon was in
the scene where hopper has his major
showdown with the demogorgon the duffer
brothers really wanted to try and do
that entire scene in one shot but
unfortunately because of how dangerous
the stunts were they were not able to do
that we didn't want to be using cg
people on top of a cg so we weren't able
to do it all in one shot they wanted to
protect their stunt team so they did
three big stunt sequences and stitched
them all together would you have been
able to tell
the americans are very tricky
number three
it takes a lot of work an entire team of
people in fact to make vechna look as
horrifying as he did the actor jamie
campbell bauer went through an egregious
eight and a half hour prosthetic
application every time he had to play
vecna one thing they couldn't do with
prosthetics though was remove his nose
on each application day we had a black
nose on jamie with some little white
marking dots so vfx could remove that in
post vfx also added in those creepy
slithering vines coming out of vecna's
back time for you
to join me
number four speaking of vechna his eight
and a half hour prosthetic seems to pay
off because the cast was typically very
frightened whenever they chewed a scene
with him vecna was pretty much fully
practical effects made it easier for me
so i'm not like staring at a man in a
green suit sadie sang also spent a great
deal of her time in a harness rehearsing
for her levitation scene right before
her big showdown in the upside down
there's not a lot that you have to do
because it's genuinely just so scary
number five
one thing you might not know about
steve's journey to watergate was that it
wasn't even shot in a real lake it was
shot in a convention center in atlanta
georgia joe kiri recounts diving into a
40-foot tank specifically built for this
scene getting to do that sort of stuff
is like true
movie magic
number six
the insane shootout that destroyed every
inch of the buyer's home was also shot
in one take sean levy the director of
episode 4 was compelled to do it all in
one shot he said it was the most
challenging and most rewarding scene
he's ever directed the whole challenge
with the oner is it requires perfect
synchronicity considering they only had
one choreography session for this scene
it's fair to say they killed it
everybody needed to do their job at a
high high level of near perfection
it's a doozy
number seven
you know that part when feckness victims
are getting every bone in their body
snapped like a wishbone on thanksgiving
of course how could you forget it's
quite difficult to watch but
surprisingly not that difficult to
achieve with special effects to break
the fingers it's essentially working
with different layers of a moving hand
within adobe after effects for the legs
they utilize a much more practical
approach they need to put their arms
through the pants so they can function
as legs and with the bigger range of
motion of an arm we can now create a
twisting breaking movement who's the
fact that
[Music]
an undead creature of great power
number eight
the unique thing about stranger things
is how they blend practical effects like
makeup and prosthetics with vfx in every
scene with vfx they also heavily rely on
the makeup team as we stated earlier
jaime campbell bower worked very closely
with the makeup team so close that he
had his own team of people applying lube
onto his entire body our last 10-15
minutes would be the four of us
literally getting this product all over
him to make him look really glossy
number nine
we're all familiar with eleven's iconic
nosebleed but have you ever wondered how
they get the blood to flow at the right
time at first corn syrup a lot of it the
only time millie would get to call
action on set was when she felt it
dripping from her nose you know my nose
is running with blood so i'm like okay
are we ready it's coming three two
right because that didn't always go
according to plan they ended up using
cgi blood for those scenes in later
seasons it's fun to film but also really
stressful
number 10
the character of victor had a brutal
disfiguring after his encounter with
vecna in reality we can thank the
brilliant prosthetic work of barry dower
for victor's disturbing look the
sculpture of victor creel's appliance
which you can see the difference in tone
where the appliance finishes just prior
to robert's hairline the two-hour
process was so bad for the team because
they were able to reference actual scars
as opposed to something that is
completely fictional
i suppose
all evil
must have
a home
number 11
11 is me like 11 is just who i am now it
doesn't take very long for the cast to
transform into their characters but
millie's transformation into 11 is a
little more involved it takes about an
hour to do my old wig my makeup isn't
that crazy at all so judging by this
math you could create at least eight
elevens in the time it takes to create
one fekna jaime campbell bower we do not
envy you underneath all that molding
clay
number 12
in stranger things the upside down is
just as important as any other character
in the show so how exactly do they
create it a recurring theme we've seen
with the duffer brothers is that they
prefer to do things as practical as they
can we realized that in fact the vision
that the brothers had
was more extensive than one can always
do practically when it comes to creating
all of the upside-down creatures they
had to call on a team of cgi experts it
starts usually with a sculpture so we
digitally sculpt things so with a
mixture of practical components and a
hard-working visual effects team they
were able to create this stunning world
just beneath our own
so now you've seen it all the blend of
real-life animation mounds of
prosthetics and the iconic man in the
green suit the visual effects team
clearly works overtime in hawkins
knowing all these secrets do you think
you'd be brave enough to face becna let
us know in the comments